hey everyone delgan here so today I'm
joined by Raphael Yaki who's probably
best known to many of you for his work
on cyberpunk edge Runners the show on
Netflix and also on Witcher Ronin to
make a very long story short I recently
watched cyberpunk Edge Runners and it
immediately became my my favorite anime
I absolutely loved it I I fell in love
with it
more than I can express eloquently and
so when I learned that Raphael was going
to be in beppu I I reached out to him
and he graciously agreed to meet up so
in this video I'd like to kind of pick
his brain and uh hopefully learn more
about his creative process and all the
work that he's done in the past so
without further Ado do you mind giving a
brief self-introduction sure hi
everybody
uh as dogen has said my name is Rafael
Yaki and uh yeah I started to work in
the video game industry more than 10
years ago uh for the majority of the 10
years I was at CD project red the
company behind Witcher and cyberpunk
2077. I started off as a business person
then I kind of transitioned into a more
producer kind of thing and then a few
years back I was in charge of everything
that was in the video game but was kind
of creative so for example I was one of
the two people that came up with gwent
the mini game in Witcher 3 then I worked
on a bunch of board games for the IPS
then I made my writer's debut with what
you're Ronin which was a Kickstarter and
kind of a what if story what if Gerald
was a ronin in Japan instead of like
medieval fantasy Europe
and in the background for five years
more than five years I worked on
cyberpunket Runners to make that show
okay there are so many things that I
would like to ask you
um
first of all I think
immediately before
recording this video I I read Ronin and
I thought that was incredible by itself
of course you lived or you didn't live
in Japan but you studied Japanese at
University do you mind maybe talking
about that a little bit more sure uh
uh when I was 12 I watched
for the first time consciously was
something that was made in Japan and I
knew it was that
and for me at the moment like something
profound has opened up yes and I thought
wow they're so different but so
appealing it's
um that I want to be as close to that as
much as I can and then I went to my
first uh anime convention in my hometown
which was like 200 people or something
and then I enlisted into a like a local
Club where there was enthusiasm for
Japanese culture and funangian Anime and
then some of those people from that club
went to Warsaw University to study
Japanese philology
and they were already my senpai's from
the club and I made a plan and I talked
to my parents like I'm not going to get
good grades in high school but I'm going
to focus on the things that will get me
into Wars University Japanese philology
and I really focused on that because it
was my dream to get there and the the
story of that is funny on its own
because it was the the year that I tried
to get in
was it was the most popular curriculum
in whole my whole country interesting it
was 50 people for one space wow okay
there was only 20 available for the for
the whole country
and in order to get in you had to have
the perfect score 200 for 200 from the
um like the entrance examination yeah
yeah well not from the like the end of
high school exams okay which like in the
states is sat right and for Poland or
something different but basically the
same concept
but so it couldn't get in because I had
190 out of 200. so still quite High I
did my best but it didn't get a perfect
score uh but because it was so popular
the dean uh opened up 20 more spots okay
but everybody that was in the 100 list
whoever got then they sent an email
saying whoever gets first
uh
the next day to sign in on the uh on the
list will get in if they're in the top
hundred list okay so I slept
on the University grounds just to make
sure that I could get in nice nice and
it was a you know more of a pressure
perseverance thing that kind of you know
a luck thing maybe but it opened up that
way and yeah and I went through uh three
years first of my bachelor's degree and
then I went to do my master's degrees
that I didn't actually finish I I was I
was on the year five but I already had a
pretty steady job and I knew that I
wouldn't become a translator or I
wouldn't go to a Japanese you know
Factory company that for me to to pursue
that future and it was always like a
passion thing for me so I really got a
good job at that time so I was like I
can't do job and University at the same
time so I I dropped out after uh year
five so it didn't finish the Master's
Degree I did finish my bachelor but yeah
there was an interview before I got in
and there was a rule you cannot mention
any pop culture if you want to get it if
you do you're not going to get in okay
because the thing is the anime no
nothing because the thing was that and I
actually understood later on was that
um
if that was the if you're not obsessed
and that was your motivation you thought
you're going to get into
closer to anime because you went there
that was not the case like we studied
Tea Ceremony we started Japanese history
like the the food culture all the
language you know grueling amount of
kanjis each week
and it's if anime was your only
motivation all those people dropped out
I was the only one that actually because
I had in that interest in everything
that was Japan right yeah you know manga
and I mean it wasn't the only thing I
was interested in so because of that I
persevered but people that went into
just for that they burned out
very quickly okay okay got it yeah it
makes sense makes sense I think we kind
of were similar in that sense because I
of course was always a big anime fan but
I wasn't anime
otaku in the sense of anime was my life
I was
the name dogen comes from the Zen
Buddhist priest because I was very into
Zen Buddhism as well on top of anime and
then all throughout Marshall all
throughout High School I did tricking
which is kind of like Freestyle martial
arts acrobatics which was of course Very
inspired by
East Asian martial arts so I was very
into like karate as well so that
multiple parts of the culture I was very
into so very similar in that regard
um you weren't able to talk about anime
though but one of the questions that I
would like to ask you is what are some
of the inspirations
what are some of the works of art be
they anime be they movies whatever they
might be what are your favorite pieces
that inspired you while working on The
Witcher while working on Ronin while
working on cyberpunk Etc
well
there's so many I don't know I've got
enough time but I think uh there's a
couple of pieces of media that really
moved me to my core the one that really
changed my life uh was neogenesis
Evangelion and I watched it in uh files
because obviously I had to Pirate them
because in Poland after the Communist
time you couldn't get the legal copy of
such a thing so I downloaded it through
the internet and it was 16 megabytes
files you couldn't see almost nothing it
was because there were like 320 to 240
ratio
but I watched it and
[Music]
I've I thought something has changed I
didn't truly understand what but I had
feelings that I'd never had before
I opened up like a shelf that wasn't I
didn't even know that existed yeah and
from that point I thought oh that's
that's a Creator voice that really was
shouting to me something it was a very
unique experience because outside of
like a family tie maybe with close
friends nobody transferred emotions like
yes at all right right uh so I think
Evangelion to me still till till this
this day is such an important piece of
media and actually the the last movie
The News yeah that that came out
recently I was I was obviously crying at
the end but I was like oh hidakiano is
fine now and he's he because his work on
Evangelion shows like his states of
depression but now after this movie he's
he's a hap he's happy interesting and I
was like I'm so happy for you as a
creator that you you know for 20 years
you went through this roller coaster of
who you are what do you want to express
and now you're happy and such a like he
he just went there and showed all his to
the whole world his whole emotional life
is it inside core and was such an
interesting thing to see it but at the
end I was so happy right he was happy
now yeah very kind of cathartic moment
yeah now
I think this is like the perfect
transition to a question that I've been
wanting to ask
so many people for a very long time and
I think you're probably like the most
qualified person to answer this question
which is
the reason that cyberpunk edge Runners
is my favorite anime now is because
I believe that it it is like the essence
of
wonderful concentrated storytelling and
there are no frills and there is nothing
that doesn't need to be there
um we right before this we started
talking very briefly about Aristotle's
Poetics one of the lines that Aristotle
has in that is
um
it's very blunt and it says episodic
content basically is the worst type
because in taking a struggle that
becomes episodic if you try and take the
struggle in that exists throughout the
the proper the entire timeline
but then you add in filler content it
dilutes the struggle and we don't really
relate to characters so much as much as
we do with them going through the
struggle right that's what I've always
thought and that's what I loved so much
about Edge Runners it was so
concentrated there was nothing that
could not be included everything was had
its place in the story and it was the
exact I mean it was split into episodes
but it certainly wasn't it exactly
exactly one unified story brilliant and
one of the things that I said to you in
the car earlier earlier on was I think
it's better better than Cowboy Bebop I
might get people that try and cancel me
for that but one of the reasons for that
is because I absolutely love Cowboy
Bebop it's it's a masterpiece of of
course but
the only critique I have of Cowboy Bebop
is that to me it felt like there were a
few episodes that weren't related to the
story at Large
where they would go do something and
come back and in that sense it felt like
the store the series had a little bit of
downtime
and again Edge Runners didn't feel that
way at all I was riveted I was on the
edge of my seat the entire time okay
next episode next episode perfect
perfect now the real question is
neogenesis Evangelion as well is is a
landmark of anime
I've always had a very difficult time
figuring out my opinion on it because
another thing that Aristotle wrote in in
that same paragraph is that if you take
a series that's more or less complete or
or a story that has these characters and
you try and stretch it
stretch it at all you end up
against kind of diluting it and of
course with neogenesis Evangelion there
was the first season and then there were
the couple like movies that came after
that yeah and then there were a couple
movies kind of after that and then I
believe that the the reason the most
recent movie that came out is supposed
to be kind of like the proper ant yeah
now at least the the end that the
Creator wanted all along but couldn't
get to but after 20 years he finally got
to the end of the division yes yes and
this is kind of like my question is
I I watched the original
just the the first I believe 2426
episode series and I absolutely loved it
and I thought it was the greatest anime
ever made
until the last couple episodes where
things kind of get crazy and I believe
it's it's my understanding that
they kind of it didn't have the budget
to make it as they wanted or or there's
speculation how yeah how it kind of came
about right I think but
I can ask the people that were there
because trigger actually has the
majority of gynex people that did yeah
but I think it was mostly I think budget
one is time-wise which is always
constrained with anime but also the
emotional state of a Creator because he
at that time was as I think he talked
about it and there's a manga where he
draws him well he draws his life and
kind of struggles uh and he said that he
was just a wreck he couldn't finish okay
so and I think it's shows in the work
because you know at the end it's like
there's no hope the wrong choices are
made everything gets [ __ ] and it's
like and it's it's so depressing because
it was supposed to be that like that was
the emotional state of the Creator at
that point and I think it transfers to
the audience okay very very interesting
I hadn't really thought about it what
would you say about zooming out and
thinking about the mental state of the
the character or the the Creator I was
I try and concentrate more on on just
the series yeah yeah as it is and again
in that sense that's what made Edge
Runner so special to me is it just felt
like every piece was in in in the right
spot but
anyway
um let's see
when you originally were working on
multiple things within CD projekt Red
and then your first big creative
Endeavor was Witcher Ronin yeah the one
that I kind of had really creative
ownership yeah in a sense that was my
idea from the start to kind of bring
Carol to the different setting and what
if scenario in a sense that what if it
wasn't oh a portal opened up and a
medieval character goes to Japan but
rather what would happen if the
character with his own traits would be
born in a fantasy Japan rather than the
medieval European setting right and from
that point it was quite easy to me to
make that jump because I'm like you know
I'm a fan of all those things and for me
taking like a
yokais that are really cool and got a
little bit flatlined in like the general
culture yes for example kappas are like
oh they're just like this funny yeah you
know but they were like you know
mischievous and they had like their own
special quirks and and if you get center
around the story which which you're
always is it's like you know he is a
Monster Hunter and the monster and his
uh
special things are part of an
investigation that he always does I
thought in Japanese it would work but
also it was the case that for Ronin and
for girls whenever we would come to
Japan Japanese people would always tell
me that he is he's a ronin like he is a
character goes from Village to Village
yeah no job yeah does a job for a small
coin he just wants you know to be left
alone basically and I felt that that is
true of what a Japanese typical
character or like
kind of character is so I thought it's
the jump would be easy
I hope it was for the reader I hope it
was enjoyable in that sense yeah I
absolutely I just read it again
immediately before this and I I loved it
now naturally there are multiple art
styles in it was this something that you
had in mind from the get-go or or or did
you have that idea as you were creating
it
here the producer in me kind of kicks in
okay in a sense that hataya
the artist for the main Arc of the comic
book yes
she can only produce so much art in the
time frame right
and
getting more artists involved made it
possible from the production standpoint
okay sorry from the production
standpoint to
actually have uh a bigger comic book
because she
and rightfully so took more than a year
to just do the art for this so I I
thought there's a bunch of Japanese
creators that I found I wanted to do
something with let's make short stories
with them to kind of showcase different
aspects of this world but still kind of
uh to the core concept of the IP of what
is which are about and I and I love
working with artists because I write
comic books in a
just like uh
uh screen Jesus Christ I forgot the name
scream screen screenplay yeah just like
a screenplay because normally right now
in comic books especially in American
comic books there's a lot of um
directing and writing at the same time
so the writer becomes a director because
while he writes the script he also
directs the artist in how it is done
interesting in a sense that they will
say okay so four panels on a page first
panel geralt looks right and he sees
this and this the emotions this and this
please do it in a blue way and and his
basically a film director at that point
yes not no longer a scriptwriter he's
yes he's the director yes I don't write
that way I don't like kids to be honest
because I feel there's very little left
for the artist to interpret yeah that's
um
yes so so all of Iranian was written in
a way that is just like you know a
screenplay which is like geralt enters
the room there's this and this and this
and this is the dialogue and this leaves
a lot of interpretation for the artist
that's why I love to work with different
artists because they can interpret the
situation on their own yes and more
likely than not I'll be delighted with
their creativity yes yes absolutely
absolutely
um
there's just so many so many questions
are there any well of course we talked a
little bit earlier about your
Inspirations the the main one being
um
Evangelion
but in terms of writing
are there any
what would you say rules or guidelines
that you try and have for yourself while
you're writing or any do you have like a
routine or anything like that that you
follow well I think uh I'm very much
like my teacher here
who is also the uh he wrote the
screenplay for Edge Runners yeah he
taught me how to do Ronin because he's a
comic book creator for 15 years now and
he worked in TV for many years before
this and of course I had many great
writers for video games but writing for
video games is very different I must
very different Beast so like the linear
storytelling that you do in comic books
or in anime or movies it's quite
different as well uh so I learned what I
know from Bartos just working with him
on this and he gave me two really great
tips that I try to follow the first one
being the dramatic question yes the
thing that if you have something
important in your life there's a
question that kind of fills you and you
need to explore it try to do the the
thing that you want with that dramatic
question in mind because if you there's
a difference between story and the
plotline right story being what happens
if a family member dies and the plotline
is somebody's going to the funeral they
go to the city and they have this
adventure you have the obstacle
structure and maybe the hero's journey
whatever that would be but it's without
the question it has no substance it's
just things happening to the character
yes and that dramatic question is
parallel for this for a story to be good
I agree 100 it's funny you mentioned
that I
I took a master class that Aaron Sorkin
did I saw it as well oh really yeah yeah
I mean that's exactly what he says he
says you need to have intention and the
obstacle because if you don't you're
just going to end up writing a story
about like the road trip that you have
rather than
the struggle yeah
yeah and then and in that Master Class
as well was the the depiction of like
you know the difference between story
and plotline is that the story is uh
somebody is estranged with their family
and they want to get together for
Christmas but this this could be a
comedy this could be uh
okay so the the thing is that it could
be a comedy it could be a drama it could
be something in between it could be
animated it could be live action could
be anything at that point because you're
trying to explore that dramatic question
and the obstacles will emerge based on
that dramatic question
so for me for example for Edge Runners
yes and what bartek really really while
we were developing he arrived at the
dramatic question that is the final
question that you see in the show is
like can you leave can you live somebody
else's dreams and
the dreams part was enforced in every
single piece of edge Runners to make it
stronger because then a relatively small
piece of like 10 episodes 20 minutes
plus
can have some power absolutely but
without it it would be just like think
about other things like you know I shot
an anime you have 300 episodes
and it's great I love this kind of stuff
but maybe the dramatic question has to
change like each
and you have to pursue and you have to
make sure that the audience is still in
with you yeah a dramatic question
because for example one piece has that
such a long running piece of media I
love it like it's with me for 20 plus
years and it's something that I I'm
actually very fearful that it will end
because it was said it will go to that
very quickly like not very quickly soon
I don't know what will happen in my life
if there is no weekly one piece but what
I was trying to say is that he changes
the dramatic question over the course of
this uh right of his series and he
explores different questions and he you
can cut one piece into different
type of things and take them out and
maybe some context will be lost but
they're very different dramatic
questions like he explores you know a
question about slavery a question about
being free a question of like is safe
okay even if it's oppressed and there's
many of those questions and he explores
them and then he shifts to another
because it's such a long-running piece
but if you are have this really
important question you want to ask you
if you have something inside of you and
you cannot find the answer to that
question but it constantly comes back to
you that most likely is a creative you
should explore what happens if you want
to answer this question because you
might not arrive to the answer even if
you think you know it but exploring that
dramatic question is something that I
was taught by Bartos and I think I
became a decent
of that learnings yes of like having
that starting point of okay do you have
something to say to this world yes yes
and if you do what is it like for
example one of the things that I'm uh
that is important for me is like when I
became a dad like a new dramatic
question popped up it's like I'm so
afraid that my something will happen to
my kid and what will happen to me if
that happens like do I want to live
anymore maybe not I don't know and
exploring for example what happens with
you as you as a parent there's a bunch
of really cool video games right now
that are exploring these questions like
Last of Us or God of War where it's like
creators that had this question made
pieces of media about this what what it
means to be a father what it means to be
a parent what is a loss of a child do to
you can you re-engage with the world
after that happens to you those are
important questions and you can see
through those excellent pieces of
content yes art I want art art say it
you can see that they had this in mind
all the time and every single piece of
those art pieces is stronger because
somebody thought about it if there was a
if there was a problem to solve most
likely the dramatic question will help
you in fixing that if something doesn't
feel right it's interesting you say that
one of my favorite albums
is it's called Merryweather Post
Pavilion by this american band
um I believe they're American Animal
Collective and the opening it's actually
the second song but there's kind of like
a Prelude to to that it's like the first
proper song on the album It's called my
girls and I think I'm getting this right
but it was the first
one of the first songs that they wrote
since one of the band's members
became a father and it's such a powerful
song and in in that sense I can very
much relate
to to what you're saying when
how the dramatic question changes in
trying to explore that in different
means of art it's
probably what makes great art great and
I think you know Edge Runners clicked
for you and it's good for a lot of
people which I'm you know so grateful
for it's you know having the feedback
but there's a lot of people that it
didn't click for and I you know I go
through edits and I read all those
people most likely oh it was too short
and I wanted to spend more time with the
characters I didn't understand why Lucy
didn't tell David something something
and because of that oh that she's
actually responsible for the demise of
the whole crew because I'm like kind of
but it's not about that right it's not
it's and I but I understand they didn't
click with the question because maybe
that maybe they haven't had that
experience or or the question wasn't
relevant for their for the thing that
they have in their mind or they want to
explore yes it's very yeah very very
true
yes I very much understand that as well
I'm
I haven't talked about this yet we
talked about it earlier I'm working on
this new project right now and I'm not
going to get into too many details right
now but this is something that has I've
been struggling with which is will the
people that watch this understand
not necessarily what I'm trying to say
but the thoughts that I'm trying to
explore
so I can very much appreciate that
sentiment now exploring the dramatic
question was I think you said there were
two things that you learned from him do
you mind saying what the second was this
the second thing was just the
that you are as a creative
it's mostly about problem solving
actually and Imagination in a sense that
even if your technical writing skills
aren't amazing there are ways for you to
have
to tell your story even without you
writing amazing dialogues for example
there are ways for you to find that but
you have to have problem solving your
imagination I get a lot of my my email
is public on my Twitter like right after
it Runners there was a you know a bunch
of people that wrote to me about you
know how can I make my own anime I have
this idea
and I try to be as much you know I don't
have that much time but I'm trying to
respond to those to those emails and for
most of like I have this idea the idea
itself not that important what is
important is that can you make that idea
a reality can you push through the phase
of like
okay this I think this would be an
interesting story maybe the dramatic
question is already with me but what
happens next how do you put the work in
to actually make it happen and for many
people that I interact with is like I
have this idea take the idea and make it
for me and I'm like that doesn't work
right you have to do the actual work
with the people if you want to make
something and then you know I get a lot
of other questions of like oh I have
this idea should I become a screenwriter
should I become an artist should I
become this is like
pick one lane yeah most likely yeah and
just go for it and you know if at first
everybody that starts something they
were quite bad at it and absolutely and
then they become better if they stay
with it like one of the most revealing
thing and it's a different colleague
that actually gave me something super
interesting like so I'm always envious
of people that have uh manual skills of
like being an illustrator for example a
concept artist and I was so jealous
always because I'm super [ __ ] at it and
I told I got drunk with my with my pal
he's one of the greatest concept artists
in the world like actually top hundreds
globally CD project right yeah and I
told him and I told him look you're so
talented I'm so jealous he's like he
said I hope I can swear yes he said he
said [ __ ] off I'm not talented I'm doing
this 10 out 10 hours a day for 20 years
I put the work in if you would put the
work you would be maybe not in the same
spot and I but you would be a working
talented individual on the industry with
regards to everything so it is the work
that you actually put in in your mind
and
you have different things to offer to
the world even if you think you don't
but you have to stay with it and do it
absolutely one of the things that one of
my YouTube friends told me early on when
I was starting on YouTube is he said
if you're confident in your ability it's
not whether or not you will succeed it's
when you will succeed and I strongly
believe that and that was kind of the
mentality that I tried to
maintain throughout those first couple
years of really grinding on YouTube but
yeah I definitely agree with that
sentiment
is it okay for you to talk about your
new Endeavors at all
I can say that I'm working on stuff but
not what I'm working on exactly okay um
maybe I should rephrase that in the
sense of not necessarily the work itself
but you did all this incredible work at
CD project red can you speak about your
decision to leave what you would like to
do
going forward
I think you know now that you've had the
most successful you know anime in the
world and well I think first of all it
just wasn't just me like there was
hundreds of people that did it
because of course yeah it's important
like there was people that you know lost
as much sleep as I did on the project so
um but for me you know I had this free
lanes that I kind of know how to do well
one is just a business person that knows
how to you know do licensing a deal how
to structure a piano and everything like
that the other is a producer ability of
like fighting Talent building teams
making sure that things get delivered
and if there's problems solve them right
and the third is being just a creative
that just has ideas and know how to
bring them to life it's such a unique
in my experience to have each of those
skills I consider myself someone that
has a little bit of business knowledge
and I've done a little bit of producer
stuff in the past like at a very very
small level at previous jobs and stuff
like that but I'm much more
um feel I'm I'm more on on the creative
side of things but for for you do you
feel like it's kind of an even balance
of all three
I
I
think
in order is there one that you're most
passionate about well the third part is
the one that I want to pursue the most
okay being the creative but I think my
most experience is the producer the
business person
and you know I've worked with creatives
and been a part of creative teams for 10
years in the industry but
me leading such things as way less time
because the anime before it really you
know started it was like two years of
trying to do pre-production and I was in
charge of that still but
it was you know
maybe one day a week in that sense after
that when real pre-production started
was more and more and more and I became
more and more involved and kind of felt
that ownership over the whole project
because it became real it wasn't just oh
we signed some papers and now it's
something but it really became something
and it started to to become real uh so
my mix of abilities I want to kind of
lean into all of them because I think
they make me a better Creator if that
makes sense yes because from a from a
you know production perspective I'm no
longer a dream not no longer I was never
a dreamer in the sense of like oh I have
this great idea I'll just bring it to
the world and this will be it no I have
to find teams there are deadlines
there's money and you have to find a way
to actually make it work because it's
just not the only thing that you have a
dream and it will magically appear
absolutely and you have to have the
business Acumen of pursuing persuading
people
to allow you to do the thing because you
know for example if I have a the most
amazing script for a Batman comic book I
still have to go to the owner of the IP
and say I have this amazing idea and I
have to pitch it in a way but they will
listen I'm sure they get tons of emails
like I have this great but my idea right
of course notoriety helps like I already
am established that's yes some people
will listen but at the same time some
won't so we still have to have that
skill of presenting it in a way for for
this to be a win-win situation in a
sense that I try to assemble my teams
and we talked about it yes uh in a way
that it's not only about a job it's okay
this will Elevate the other next thing I
want to do or this was a I'm a such such
a huge fan of the IP I want to work with
on it regardless of any other
circumstances there's trying to find
those people it's always uh a thing that
brings me joy in that sense but I think
I have at least two dramatic questions
that I want to explore in the future
okay and I want to do stuff with them uh
but then that's on the creative side but
on the producer side I want to support
people that have those questions and
maybe they don't know how to do it but
the question is cool and I want to know
the answer to it as well I want to help
them realize this as well very
interesting yeah I think it's
you're in a very unique situation in the
sense that because you have all three of
those skills
even if you know
hypothetical situation there's someone
that is objectively better at one of
these things than you are because you
have experience in all three even if
they do have this incredible idea you
also have I don't know if the
wherewithal is the right word or not but
you can zoom out enough to to see okay
yeah the story itself is incredible but
this isn't going to make it to Market
because of this
and so uh
in that sense I'm really excited for the
next thing that you put out because
you've got the everything you've got
your your view is wide enough to see
everything
that needs to be considered in order to
make something great
and I think also I try to lean into my
strengths yeah Japan is my specialty and
because of that edge Runners is not a
live action TV show it's an anime
because I not you know had a bucket list
until I'm 35 I want to make you know
work on a global globally Successful
video game I want to make a card game I
want to make a board game I want to make
my own manga and I want to make my anime
and my bucket list is full like I did
everything that I had nothing but it was
such a silly thing right it's like a guy
that lived in a small village in Poland
wants to do those things and it's it's
Preposterous in that sense but it kind
of first started in a different place
and then I tried to find a way to push
the boundary a little of like okay maybe
I'm not a writer yet but let me co-write
something with somebody else let me be
close to the writers so I can learn from
them let me try to be as useful as I can
with the skills that I currently own to
get new skills so I can be even better
at the things that I do because
also from the conversations I'm having
with you know younger people is like oh
I just you know want to immediately make
via Creator make my own show it's like
that's not a realistic path to anything
or are these if you're not in the author
of Chainsaw man which is he's 28 and he
wrote Such amazing pieces already that
I'm like in awe that he does but that's
not the that's the genius path or maybe
I think he's a hard worker for sure as
well so it's not I don't want to you
know reduce him to a genius but he has a
a mix that I don't think anybody else
maybe in the world has but my was that I
tried to leverage my usefulness to
anything that I do and then because of
that just make a step toward the
direction I felt passionate about right
with keeping a little bit of a safety
net in the sense that I still if none of
my creative things would be good from
this point on I did this already and I
also have my you know business people
will be I think needed for forever maybe
so it's like a safe thing that I can do
but I also bring to the table and that
in a sense that it's no longer oh I have
this
go to a meeting room and say like oh
this is the idea but I say oh this is
the idea and this is how we execute this
idea yes yes absolutely and this helps a
lot into bringing confidence into new
crazy projects because every single
project I did was crazy at first like it
was never going to become a reality it
was just like let's explore if this is
even a possibility but because of that
okay so now I put my producer hat and
now I put my business hat and now I
bring my Creator hat uh I can change
those hats then my usefulness in the
room is high because of it yeah I would
have loved to
have been a fly on the wall for some of
those conversations that you must have
had at CD project red where you're
pitching maybe we could make a comic out
of this maybe we can make a board game
out of this maybe we can make an anime
out of this and because of course
again going back to the very business
perspective we have to be realistic with
numbers yeah yeah it's a great idea but
we can't make it happen if we're not
able to pay the wages necessary sure the
one thing that I would like to say is
that I'm so grateful for everybody to
watch the show and you know you gave me
such high praise and I'm so happy that
people connect to the work because I
think that the feeling that you that
I've described with neogenism and go is
like
if I can be that person to give
something new to somebody just one
person in the world I'll be the happiest
ever yeah
um if you don't mind me sharing a little
bit of the conversation that we had in
the car earlier
um I've had three experiences in my life
that where I was so moved by a
particular piece of art that had changed
the course of my life the first being
when I found this Japanese punk band
when I was 13 that inspired me to study
Japanese uh the second being the first
time I went to a shinaringo Tokyo jihen
concert when I was about to give up
about to give up writing because it was
very hard and I wasn't making a lot of
progress and the third being
after watching Edge Runners all you guys
know me as as Dogan the YouTuber who
does uh of course Japanese related
language stuff but um
I'm since watching this show I've
decided to try and uh pursue at the same
time this other project that I'm looking
forward to sharing with all you guys in
the future so again I can't praise the
show enough and
one other thought that I would like to
um are trying to articulate is that
one thing you just mentioned is that the
people that
didn't necessarily resonate too much
with Edge Runners were the audience that
maybe
weren't in a position where they could
relate to the dramatic question now as
someone who
considers themselves a writer or
whatever
I always watch
um movies and Anime or any kind of story
with a very analytical eye and we talked
about this a little bit as well but
I try and be super critical when I'm
watching basically everything because I
try and see what I can learn from that
of course
and that's what blew me away so much
about Edge Runners because normally
there's 50 different things that oh
I can think up of that feel a little bit
off to me
for any content and you brought up
chainsaw man a second ago like what one
example of this is I'm also watching it
right now and that's the whole world is
yes as the whole world is one thing that
felt a little bit off to me
of the many things that I wrote down in
that first episode was
um denji is fighting the Demon in the
first episode and one of the lines that
the demon has is
so he says why are you still alive even
though I sliced you up into little bits
and I thought
the the bit that kind of felt a little
bit strange to me there was two things
about that that felt a little bit off
one being that we've is it necessary to
pose that question at all as we've just
seen it
it's
is it potentially redundant not not
terribly but the the main thing is that
in having the demon use the word which
is kind of like
um slang it it feels like the demon is
cheapened slightly to me
I felt when I remember that line for me
it was that it's
and I don't know the intention of the
author of course of course for me it was
like
actually it humanizes the demon in the
sense that oh demons speak that way
because they are as [ __ ] up as humans
and for me without that I would think
about the demon just as a monster but
once that line arrives I'm like okay so
they have this complexity that is only
for humans in in themselves so they
might be dumb they might be smart but
they might be appalled they might be
like and because of that I was like
that's an interesting choice choice to
make to
potentially pay off later yeah and I was
actually able to reconcile that a little
bit with there's a line towards I think
the end of the second episode where
hayakala another one of the characters
is speaking with denji after denji has
killed a devil and
uh hayakawa basically you know he says
well why didn't you just like use your
powers to kill him and then she says I
didn't want to make him suffer
unnecessarily and hayakawa then comes
back and he says
well don't sympathize with the Enemy do
you want to be friends with the devil
and then this incredible line that denji
then says after that is well if a devil
wants to be friends with me then yeah
because I don't have any friends and
that tells us so much about denji but it
also tells us about the complexity of
the Devils as well yeah so yeah because
I think this and that's the Brilliance
of him as a writer yeah yeah in the
sense that he's already setting up
something that will be way in the future
for the series that says that you have
to because I read the whole manga right
all right now it's volume like the the
second coming of Chainsaw man for for
the manga but I read the whole thing and
later on without much spoiler it is a
huge dramatic questions like can a
person that's terrible be good yeah it's
um and it's and it depends because of
that setup and because of that deepening
of that setup that is an amazing thing
that like I as a writer cannot do yet in
a sense that having such a long-running
thing and having those all the tidbits
planned out yeah so meticulously
maybe it is something that happens but
from my experience most likely there was
some intuition there but it might have
not been planned out completely because
planning out such a thing with my new
details
requires a huge brain like not in a like
in a capacity way because if you write
it down then it becomes the thing that
is written down either you have it in
your brain and you already have the
thought process in it and I think if you
are a person like that you might not
have anything else in your life that's
happening you might be obsessed and then
it might be possible but if you're not
then it might be more intuition than
anything else to plant those seeds to
really grow yeah because if you look at
George R Martin for example he knows
where it ends but the reason why it
takes him so long is that he knows what
it is puts the pieces in writing oh this
feels off I have to twist this but
because I twisted it then it has to
reconcile something that's already out
and written yes yes but also something
that he wrote maybe that wasn't public
yet but he can rewrite it so he's
constantly rewriting stuff that he
already wrote because he's writing new
ideas that he didn't think about while
he was writing absolutely so absolutely
that's kind of a conundrum of like a
very long piece of media yeah
yeah absolutely the going back to
again I haven't read chainsaw man so I
don't know how it turns out I don't know
if you're talking about the protagonist
or not and we won't get into spoiler
territory but one of the things that
stands out about it so much for me is
the way how they kind of flip the
typical Shonen hero on its head in the
sense that most of these Shonen Heroes
they come from miserable circumstances
and despite this have strong characters
yeah to the point where it's without
what would you say
um Foundation yeah yeah like it's it
they're they have morals to a t yeah
whereas
there's a great scene in chainsaw man
where Genji's fighting this this kind of
bat demon I think in episode three three
episode three yeah and
there's a civilian in the car that gets
in the way of the fight and he just like
tosses it out the side yeah first the
setup is even greater the bat says oh
you're not going to use the car because
there's a human inside and then she says
oh [ __ ] that exactly exactly so the the
setup is so interesting because it's not
that he comes from this miserable
circumstance and yet has the strong
morals it's that there are some
underlying strong morals but at least
the the premise is that he comes from
this miserable setup and has atypical
morals that we're not used to but we can
still relate despite that given his
struggle within the he's a consistently
written character and because of that
consistency it's acceptable for the
audience to sympathize with him
absolutely I I wrote down exactly what
you just said in like my notebook as I'm
going through the series right now but
it's it's just fascinating to be able to
speak
with someone with your background that
is able to
again you you come from a fundamentally
different different background than what
I do and
going back to one other thing that we
said before recording this video is that
I live in this world of of YouTube and
YouTube is great because as you
mentioned you have complete
um creative freedom you can kind of
choose what you want to do to a certain
extent of course your audience does want
you to do some things and you know it's
you have to lean you have to kind of
navigate that in a certain sense but
um I've always been
much more interested in making
greater art
and again in that sense it's wonderful
to have this opportunity to speak with
you someone who created something so
fantastic so
um
that might be a good way to end it
um I I hope that you guys were able to
learn some things from our conversation
learn from Raphael if you haven't seen
Edge runners or if you haven't seen if
you haven't read uh Witcher Ronin which
was his first major con major creative
Endeavor I would highly encourage you to
check them both out again for me
my favorite anime since College was
always monster I'm not sure if you know
it or not yeah Dr Tenma of course that
was my favorite anime but so we topped
monsters yes for me like not sure man
not sure
well anyway uh it immediately became my
favorite anime and I I try not to go
into too many details uh about the anime
specifically because you've done that on
different interviews and I would
encourage everyone to check it out but
before that I would say just go watch
the anime it's a masterpiece it's it's a
landmark and I can't wait to see what
you do next so thank you very much for
your time thank you so much was a
pleasure talking yeah and uh we'll see
you guys again soon
foreign